good morning John it's Wednesday July
18th I'm gonna have to wait till Friday
to do the green hair thing because today
is Wednesday it's my Wednesday which
means I need to write a song it's a
pretty long song I have to fit it all in
it's about Harry Potter I'm getting kind
of tired of this pre-publication media
blitz you got all of muggle kind undo
your spell
don't you know the whole one's already
gone to reserve a copy at Amazon how
many more folks could you sell
just give me my Booker got a half cuz I
need Harry Potter like granny load needs
water and hat Saturday approaches my
negro
yo Deathly Hallows incendio book sales
of autos it'll feel like Phoenix tears
on a broken nose whoa a bo deathly
hallows yeah yeah definitely
I'm petrified while Angela for mine he
died or if Baltimore killed Hedwig just
free cups
I have no confidence in theories about
the half-blood Prince if what if Harry
brings a Horcrux
holy crap that quit freaking saw cuz I
need Harry Potter like Randy load these
water and hat sir day approaches my
negro
Deathly Hallows incendio Brooks tells
about it'll feel like Phoenix tears our
broken nose yeah SEO deathly
what Evers up the sleeve of JK rowling I
bet has to do a sneaker bring believe
I'm going to protect that pure but pass
space Malfoy
but Indiana don't thing's gonna run our
name is good or as bad because the
weight of the world rests on our boy
yeah the weight of the wondrous unarmed
boy cuz we need Harry Potter like granny
Loney's water and hat Saturday
approaches are Negroes yeah yo Deathly
Hallows incendio versailles and bottles
of the flowing Phoenix tears a broken
nose yeah SEO Deathly Hallows
Accio Deathly Hallows yeah SEO
definitely
yeah actio definitely hello
right now I'm just feeling sad I know
this could end real bad but I wish it
didn't have to end at all
yeah I wish it didn't have to end
because I couldn't care more about Harry
Potter if Hollis was my alma mater and
as Saturday approaches my negro
yeah xeo definite incendio group sales
the bottles it'll feel like Phoenix
tears on a broken nose whoa Accio
Deathly Hallows yeah
XE o deathly hallows whoa
Accio Deathly Hallows
yeah hexanol deadly ha ha
these glasses are actually mine they
belong to my brother I don't know if you
can see that but they are actually
Armani glasses and I am not cool enough
to have Armani glasses I'll see you guys
in the new year with Brotherhood 3.0 bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
thank you for laboum distro for the
amazing intro go check out his videos
and stuff yeah the pain of the workers
are my cuz we need but in the end I
don't things gonna matter soon whatever
but in the end I don't think it's gonna
matter its name is good or if he's bad
because if wait up the workers are
Barbara I'll sleep